Do physicians actually prefer EMRs
with innovative approaches to data
collection?
This 2009 survey from
the American Academy of Family Practice
suggests the answer is yes.
Here physician choices are analyzed
based on practice size.
The lighter colors are small practices.
The darker colors are larger practices.
It's important to recognize
that smaller practices
tend to independently
make these decisions,
while larger practices tend to have
employed physicians and/or to be
aligned with a health system that often
makes an enterprise EHR choice for them.
Grouped by practice size, as you can
see, the choices are quite different.
While I don’t want to generalize based
on my own direct observations of
the systems at the top, the physicians
that chose EMRs on their own do,
in fact, pick more innovative or
well-designed solutions for
data collection like those
we’ve been discussing.